i
[Música]
a
cataluña aprobó una ley inédita de
regulación del precio de los alquileres
de las viviendas a partir de agua en los
nuevos contratos ya no se podrá superar
el precio establecido en el contrato
anterior pero también si este precio del
alquiler está por encima del índice de
referencia entonces se tendrá que bajar
el precio del alquiler las únicas
excepciones se sigan cuando se haya
realizado en el último año una obra de
mejora importante de la vivienda o si el
propietario tiene pocas ganancias esta
ley fue promovida por la asociación de
defensa del derecho al inquilino al
sindicato de juguetes que nació aquí en
cataluña hace tres años frente al brutal
aumento del alquiler que provocaba que
familias se tenían que abandonar pueblos
ciudades y barrios enteros para damos un
ejemplo aquí en barcelona en los últimos
cinco años se aumentó el precio del
alquiler del 40% a la partidos de la
derecha y grandes asociaciones del
problema
y quieren cancelar esta ley mientras que
en otras ciudades de españa se espera a
que se siga el ejemplo de la ley
catalana
[Música]
la crisis de el coronavirus también se
ha hecho evidente aquí en alemania en la
situación de vivienda en particular en
las grandes ciudades medios alemanes
informaron que miles de arrendatarios se
pusieron en contacto con los dueños de
sus apartamentos en los meses más
álgidos de la pandemia por
preocupaciones financieras aunque esos
mismos informes aclararon que se trata
de una minoría de los arrendatarios en
este país el gobierno alemán por su
parte puso en práctica un plan para
evitar que se les cancelarán los
contratos de arrendamiento a quienes por
culpa de el coronavirus no pudieron
pagar sus arriendos en los meses de
abril a junio de este año el gobierno
alemán explicó que ese programa ya
concluyó pues por un lado pudo ofrecerle
ayuda económica a muchas personas para
que precisamente pagaran sus arriendos y
por el otro lado aclaró que muchos
arrendadores y arrendatarios pudieron
ponerse de acuerdo de manera privada
[Música]
en medio de esta pandemia los inquilinos
del estado de nueva york han estado
protegidos por una ley que se aprobó
cerca de hace tres meses que permitía
controlar el aumento desmesurado de los
precios de los alquileres y además
también protegía a aquellos inquilinos
que estuvieran atravesando problemas
financieros porque impedía que fueran
desalojados eso ha estado muy bien hasta
ahora ha sido un buen parche pero los
inquilinos empiezan a estar preocupados
porque eso no es una solución la
moratoria de desalojo está a punto de
terminar extinguirá en el mes de octubre
y aunque se ha pedido que se extienda
hasta enero de momento esto todavía no
ha sido aprobado así que muchas familias
miran con preocupación cómo van a pagar
los alquileres estos próximos meses
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que
todavía no se han liberado esos 100
millones de dólares aprobados en el
senado para ayudar a los inquilinos de
aquí de nueva york- y eso que hasta el
momento ya ha habido al menos 90 mil
solicitudes de ayuda para el pago de la
vivienda
[Música]